j'ai vraiment vraiment beaucoup aimé les
histoires à la délicatesse du texte
quand on compose en général je pense pas
qu'ils aient une technique
ce que j'aime bien de moi dans le
travail à l'image c'est le fait que tout
soit possible potentiellement
j'aimerais bien qu'on fasse
deux autres de cinéma
si demain la même chose mais avec ses
notes là ok au dessus à une fois c'est
d'abord ça si on peut accompagner
l'image de de tellement de choses
différentes donc est pas une loi il n'y
a pas une règle personne ne va dire
c'était exactement ça qu'il fallait où
on peut juste trouvé ça beau ou pas beau
où ça fonctionne ça fonctionne pas et
donc du coup tout me semble être
nécessaire d'être fait de manière très
instinctive et très spontanée parce que
c'est ça qui va faire que ça va être
naturel
si la personne a été retrouvé la veille
heures prouver la cecc l'être encore les
cordes
c'est vrai que je préfère y aller petit
à petit par par couche d'abord ça est ce
qu'on aime bien ouais on aime bien parce
qu'on aime pas non mais pas en écarte
ensuite on rajoute s'appuie en rajoute
sa peur ajoute ça et c'est vrai que
c'est quelque chose de très artisanal
dans ce fonctionnement là parce que tout
se fait petit à petit tout se tissent
petit à petit et en fonction des
émotions du moment des choses peuvent
être faites de manière différente du
coup je préfère en effet d'improviser
les choses progressivement pour garder
cette souplesse de créativité si
j'écrivais tout d'un coup bas on
enregistrait tout d'un coup et puis ben
voilà c'est pourrait plus revenir en
arrière ce serait dommage quoi
et ce qui est chouette avec kunis et
qu'elle est très sensible à cet
artisanat et à cette manière
d'improviser la chose et on se fait
confiance mutuellement elle vraiment
vraiment fait confiance et c'est hyper
agréable
il ya pas mal de me le dire dans ce film
quand même là il y en a au moins trois
ou quatre
comme il n'y a pas des masses de musique
si tout de suite on propose plein de
mélodies radicalement différente
on perd un peu le propos il ya quand
même il ya quand même un fil conducteur
dans cette histoire il ya quand même des
émotions qui sont sensiblement les mêmes
mais travailler de manière différente
etc
mais tout le long du film donc il faut
qu'ils aient une thématique musicale qui
s'accorde à cette homogénéité là donc il
y a en fait ils trois ou quatre thèmes
différents comme dans n'importe quel
film mais je les ai traités de manière à
ce qu'il ya une forme de logique qui
fait qu' on n'est pas tellement
déboussolé d'un thème à l'autre parfois
il ya deux différences un peu plus
importante
mais globalement on a l'impression que
ces deux là même c'est la même famille
parce qu'il faut réussir à faire une
musique qu'on entende presque pas
parfois pour que pour qu'on pour
accompagner ces comme c'est comme être
avec quelqu'un mais ne pas peser sur la
personne de passants ne pas que la
personne se sente obligé de s'occuper de
vous voyez vous êtes là vous accompagner
mais là personnel elle vous semble
presque pas et c'est une forme de
bienveillance vis-à-vis de la personne
c'est un peu pareil
c'est comme si on était avec ces gens là
c'est comme si on était avec eux à
l'écran en fait c'est comme ça que je le
vis mais faut pas qu'on boit trop quoi
mon travail c'est de réussir à
accompagner musicalement avec autant de
justesse que et la réalisation qui a été
fait qui est qui vraiment est très fine
et le jeu des acteurs click qui moi même
que je trouve vraiment particulièrement
réussi et très fin
dès le début avec uni elle m'a prévenu
dès le départ elle m'a dit voilà il ya
un endroit à la fin du film il ya un
texte et je voudrais vraiment qu'on
trouve quelqu'un pour le faire et je
sais pas qui dès qu elle de qu'elle m'a
sollicité pour rechercher avec elle moi
d'emblée je me suis dit mais dans toutes
les personnes avec qui je travaille ou
avec qui j'ai pu travailler
il y en a un qui a une voix
extraordinaire qui peut véritablement
transformer un texte pas juste en
l'incarnant mai mais sa voix est un
instrument de musique extraordinaire et
j'ai dit à osny écoute je sais pas s'il
acceptera mais j'aimerais bien qu'on me
propose à grand corps malade fabien
s'appelle fabien fabien est quelqu'un
qui dans sa voix porte une une sincérité
que je ne connais pas ailleurs bien
longtemps j'avais pensé que la pire
folie était de donner la vie en tout cas
j'en avais voulu à ceux qui veulent
avait donné
ce peu comment vouliez certains jours
c'est même pourquoi j'ai choisi de vous
regarder à 16 ans alors que vous ne
pouvez m'en vouloir je vais être autant
touchés par exemple deuxième de mozart
qu que par veille on sait où
jasey jay un peu sage et un peu ce
truc-là 2d mais autant le mainstream que
que l'art et l'essai je dirais que j'ai
pas d'école en particulier qui d'un seul
coup que je vais valoriser plus ce que
j'aime dans le cinéma c'est le fait
qu'il est tout ça qui soit englobé
dedans et qui me fasse voyager de
manière complètement différente